son cerca de 200.000 argelinos que
ayudaron al ejército francés durante la
guerra de argelia la guerra de
independencia de este país del norte de
áfrica recordemos 200.000 hombres que
cuando terminó la guerra se quedaron
muchos de ellos en el país y fueron muy
maltratados vistos como traidores por
los propios argelinos que luchaban por
la independencia y los que vinieron a
francia fueron encerrados en una suerte
de campos de refugiados algunos eran
incluso rechazados por los propios
refugiados de la época entonces esas
personas forman parte ya de la deuda
histórica complicada entre francia y
argelia por el hecho de ser una ex
colonia no es cierto así que desde el
año 2001 el presidente jacques chirac
los había reconocido cree un día el 25
de septiembre día del reconocimiento de
la memoria de los heart y luego el
presidente holanda también había dicho
que francia los había abandonado y en el
año 2018 incluso un aumento de sus
pensiones por parte del gobierno de
manuel ma chrome pero el presiente
quería ir más lejos raúl únicamente
consiste entonces esta ley de reparación
anunciada por el presidente macro no
alojar keys
efectivamente dije que quería ir más
lejos entonces ha creado o van a se va a
votar una ley de reconocimiento y de
reparación de los artículos más
importantes que vaya a quedar inscrito
dentro de las leyes francesas que no va
a ser una cosa sólo de este gobierno
sino que va a quedar inscrito por
decirlo en las leyes de la república y
además ha pedido perdón dije que quería
ir más lejos también con el uso de las
palabras ha dicho que francia tiene una
deuda histórica y les pidió perdón en
nombre del país además con decoro a
varios de ellos que estuvieron hoy en un
encuentro en el palacio del elíso eran
300 los condecoró con la legión de honor
ojo que hay muchos partidos de oposición
que ven aquí una utilización electoral
del tema de los jarc y raúl por parte
del presidente de macrón de cara a las
presidenciales del próximo año ellos son
eran 200.000 pero ahora tienen sus
descendientes son cerca de 500.000
suelen votar hacia la derecha y la
extrema derecha recordemos que dentro en
este trabajo de recuperar la memoria
histórica de armonizar las memorias de
argelia y en francia el presidente
manuel macro navía
un informe un historiador sobre varios
temas entre ellos los hard keys pero
este grupo consideraba que ese informe
era minimalista en cuanto a lo que era
la situación del oscar que simplemente
hablaba de la posibilidad de facilitar
los movimientos entre argelia y francia
de los hard keys y de su descendiente
raúl